well I think that's everything we did it
hon we're really moved in it's a new
beginning for us
things are finally going to be good do
you really think it will be better for
you they won't look for him here
we just need to make sure he doesn't
attract any attention come on let's see
how he's doing
sweetie hon y'all dressed
hey champ how do you like your new room
I know it's a big change for all of us
but son do you remember why we moved to
this bright little mountain town
he doesn't remember he doesn't remember
at all that's good that's good he
doesn't remember ah sweetie we want you
to have lots of fun here why don't you
go out and make some friends right get
outside and play son
like like normal kids we've got some
money for you on the kitchen counter
sweetie
just be back before it gets dark
yeah we love you too
come on son get out there make friends
with Guelph
yeah but banished into the forest room
that way I bet asked you first
haha you can't hold out much longer yeah
so buddy I can't hold out much longer
yeah hey no fair that's cheating
I'm gonna tell my mom thanks kids
I didn't realize he had a health potion
but my name is butters the merciful and
the paladin I'm afraid next door to you
we should be friends
dammit we're friends you should speak
with the wizard King he's been talking
about your arrival the wizard lives this
way it's a green house over there hey
where are you from
Wade you live before moving here that
Colorado oh the Grand Wizard
so you are the new kid your coming was
foretold by a Coldwell Banker I am the
wizard King but the time for talk is not
gnat let me show you my kingdom Oh who's
your new friend Eric shut up mom not now
welcome to the kingdom of Koopa keep our
weapon shop here is tended by climb a
level 14 warrior here you can see our
massive stables overseen by the level 9
Ranger Scott malkinson who has the power
of diabetes and here of course is the
breathtaking and lovely princess King
the fairest maiden in all the kingdom
don't ask why can he want it to be a
chick it's just how he seems to be
rolling random you have been sought out
new kid because humans everywhere are in
great danger I need something from you
and in return I'm prepared to allow you
into my kingdom I know you are very
excited it's time for your first quest
but first please tell us thy name
you interred douchebag is that correct
are you sure you want to keep the name
douchebag very well douchebag
you will now choose a class fighter
Mitch C or Jew a mage is like a wizard
only not as COO of I Steve never heard
of life but interesting you have so I
guess we'll never really be friends
welcome to the KKK douchebag did you you
probably can also handle our finances
hooray
now please go and visit the weapon shop
procure yourself a weapon and we shall
teach you to fat
would you like to see my where's weary
traveler perhaps you would like to hear
tips and rumors for two dollars ah a
lovely purchase ah you have procured a
weapon yes it's now time to teach you
how to fight I want you to take your new
weapon and with the bravery of another
Knight beat up that what kicks ass new
kid what I do I'm the King clad and the
King wishes to be amused go on new kid
kick his ass I'm gonna kick your ass
glad you have to wait your turn that's
lame no cloud it's like olden times you
have to wait your turn like in the
Middle Ages side I know it's lame cloud
but that's how we're [ __ ] doing it
alright douchebag bash class face in
don't be jack
oh hell yeah side your [ __ ]
alright Clyde's wearing honor in order
to hurt him I want you to hit clout as
hard as you can oh [ __ ] I think I see
blood [ __ ] nice brothels exactly what
you do to guys with armor like that okay
listen up the key to surviving in battle
is not to get hit in the box glad it's
your turn to attack douchebag protect
your box
prepare yourself yeah no no I said
protect protect your bags
ah yeah that's what I'm talking about
dude you already way better the clad
alright it's time to use your heroic
powers using your ability takes power
points or PP for George the PP if you
have a [ __ ] better day for them to
[ __ ] say hi [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the
king and I say it's pp douchebag use
your Jew ability to make Claude pay for
insulting the king we know what that
smell of his stupid face is back not to
it one more time
finish him what I was going easy take
this
hahaha dude that was awesome you're on
like pee okay okay
you prove yourself worthy juice back now
come inside the words head tonight
she'll let you see America well here it
is the reason why humans and elves are
locked in a never-ending war the relic
for which human and out were willing to
die the stick of truth just two days ago
we took the stick back from the elves
our kingdom was dang but now it's rise
for whoever controls the stick controls
the universe don't get it too young for
its power and too much for mere mortals
to look at now that you have seen the
stick of truth let's discuss your dues
being a member of my kingdom cost 995
for the first week four dollars a which
is tax-deductible someone who sounded
the alarm oh my god
Magne gay don't let them throw give it
the stick humans suck you dry up
come again climb guards just think of
truth while we defend the portraits hi
hi hi we're not playing pirates guide
this is your chance to prove yourself
hold off the [ __ ] nails at all cost
oh you want something you do it
douchebag kick these off that's it
you're Moody dude back potions will heal
you here
we'll say you can have one potion every
turn master five but please come back
this guy's pastors back try to block all
these attacks second okay if you block
all the attacks you get a counter attack
enemy on the ground we can company check
the [ __ ] out of him oh you check this
toughness ass now finish off these elves
in the name of the wizard King
great job today
you got this douche bag you're mine now
what are you waiting for douche bag that
guy's just standing there go kick his
ass man you totally ready for you dude
you can't just hit him like that you
need to try a different tactic to damage
him look at that Archer hiding behind
his friend like a would switch to your
arrows douchebag it's not gonna fit
sweetie now you can just a guy in the
back go for the pigment that [ __ ]
that's what you gave up [ __ ] with
[ __ ] game
careful douchebag that guys ready for
your arrows now you gotta try something
else
oh great job feedback
let's do this douchebag
okay that guy had to ship shields are
super weak just hit them with your
siblings hand over and over to wear them
down quickly yeah yeah that's how you do
it the other UPS let's go it down
now's your chance power attack his armor
oh that's it I'm gonna gym
well elves fall back fall back I say yes
awesome dude
take that your [ __ ] house better luck
next time
we still control the universe it's gone
what the stick of truth
bells got it
that was your one goddamn job glad to
guard the stick of sucking truth
glad you are hereby banished from space
and time what no you can't do that yeah
I can you're banished and lost in tiny
space yeah go home glad you fight for
everybody on the battlefield through
thick thick you can make you think you
can fight shut up Scott W cares what you
think
anyways we have a bigger problem now the
stick of truth has been stolen and we
must assemble our entire army in order
to get it back
let's read that for you still haven't
reported for duty my king our newest
member can take care of that douche bag
I want you to go out into the
neighborhood and find my greatest
warriors token tweek and Craig I'm
texting their pictures to your personal
inventory device now but beware the
lands outside a full of marauding drow
elves monsters and sixth-graders be sure
you're well-equipped now go and send my
warriors here